[Musica]
Grazie a tutti e sono tanto felice di
essere qui insieme per parlare di
ambiente Quanti di voi credano che
domani sia un futuro migliore alzate la
mano Chi di voi è convinto che domani
avremo un futuro migliore Ok c'è
dell'ottimismo in sala Eh già mi piace
soprattutto là in fondo c'è del bello
ottimismo Allora vi faccio vedere come
esperimento 3 immagini di cosa sta
accadendo esattamente in queste ore
mentre noi qua parliamo In questa prima
immagine vedete esattamente quello che
sta accadendo qui in Italia una cosa mai
vista prima durante un inverno e la
stessa cosa sta accadendo in alcune
valli dell'Africa come del continente
americano Una siccità mai vista
specialmente per le nostre stagioni
seconda immagine
Qui siamo in Perù come potremmo essere
nel Mediterraneo come potremmo essere
Nelle steppe della Russia incendi che
stanno distruggendo e forse per sempre
interi ecosistemi sfuggendo Delle specie
viventi che magari non rivedremo mai più
terza immagine qui Siamo invece in Sud
est asiatico nel particolare qui siamo
in Pakistan dove delle inondazioni
ancora una volta mai viste stanno
spazzando via interevillaggi che forse
non esisteranno mai più
Voi direte quanto ottimismo Vi ripeto la
stessa identica domanda ragazzi
Ora che avete visto questo Quanti di voi
credono ancora che domani sarà un mondo
migliore
qualche in mano alzata meno di prima
però sono comunque contento che gli
ottimisti laggiù rimangano quindi
vi confesso che questo mio discorso sarà
esattamente un discorso di ottimismo
quindi siamo insieme e Anzi inizio e mi
presento io sono Andrea adesso se la
Slime aiuta sono un giovane Toscano un
giovane come tanti di voi e sono qua
proprio per raccontarvi un po' quello
che stiamo facendo gli amici dicano che
ho fatto una scelta temeraria nella
semplicità ho deciso di tornare in
Italia e aprire un'azienda in Italia
quindi più temeraria di così non si
potrebbe essere
ma nel bello vi parlerò oggi esattamente
di aziende e parlerò esattamente di
questa radicalità di che si occupa di
ambiente oggi e fatemi dire in questi
giorni dove si parla di vernici sui muri
si parla detto questo che forse i più
radicali siete già Voi siete voi che
avete scelto magari di studiare
ingegneria energetica o magari legge e
pensate quale soluzione legislativa può
proteggere il creato siete voi che oggi
magari lavorate in tecnologia E state
cercando la soluzione per portare di
questo mondo migliore o chi di voi sarà
impresa e facendo impresa sì avrò
l'impresa incorata in dei veri valori
con una visione alta del futuro
esattamente oggi parleremo di tre
lettere di e s e g e SEG è la più grande
rivoluzione che sta accadendo in questo
momento di fatto stiamo dicendo al mondo
delle aziende di occuparsi non soltanto
del loro interesse ma anche di quello
che il loro impatto ambientale te lo
impatto sociale del loro impatto di
governance
e quindi alcuni voi diranno bene Io non
ho un'azienda posso anche già uscire No
aspettate pure perché vedete
le aziende non sono soltanto proprietà
di un padrone ma sono anche loro dei
beni collettivi hanno un impatto sui
nostri territori sulla nostra ricchezza
se noi non ce ne occupiamo di loro Loro
sono comunque responsabili del 70% delle
missioni che abbiamo nell'area
dell'acqua che viene a mancarci del
suolo e del suo consumo e ancora di più
Lasciatemi dire con forza
che oggi c'è bisogno di immediatamente
sfatare un mito un mito è che le aziende
Verdi le aziende che hanno il coraggio
di prendersi cura di tutto questo non
soltanto sono eticamente migliori ma
sono economicamente migliori lo sono
perché potranno avere dei ricavi più
elevati giustificando dei prezzi più
alti per la loro catena del valore lo
sono perché avranno dei costi più bassi
con un uso più parsimonioso delle
risorse sono migliori perché avranno un
valore economico di mercato più alto per
un miglior accesso al credito
semplicemente una valutazione
finanziaria migliore giustificata dal
settore in cui si occupano e forse è più
importante più importante guardando voi
vi dico che sono migliori perché avranno
un accesso al talento perché diciamocelo
ragazzi nessuno di noi vuole lavorare in
un'azienda in cui non crede
E se lo faremo lo faremo controvoglia e
quindi con dei costi di performance o lo
faremo per poco quindi con dei costi di
reclutamento
adesso si viene la prossima slide vi
racconto che tutto questo non è soltanto
la convinzione di belle parole ma è la
finanza che parla Guardate ragazzi se
voi 20 anni fa avesse messo un euro in
un normale portafoglio azionario delle
azioni delle aziende votati alla
crescita economica oggi avreste circa 15
euro Non male eh Voi direte ci sarebbe
già da poi alla cena nella realtà chi ha
fatto una scelta ancora più coraggiosa e
ancora la finanza che parla ha investito
in aziende che non soltanto cercavano la
propria crescita economica ma cercavano
anche di curarsi di questo impatto
attorno a loro oggi avrebbero restituito
in investimento due volte tanto circa 28
dollari
e loro ragazzi Voi direte bene siamo
tutti d'accordo abbiamo capito che
conviene avevo capito che è meglio basta
possiamo anche andare a casa nella
realtà la teoria economica è ancora
basata su questo concetto il concetto
che la sola responsabilità dell'impresa
è quella di aumentare i profitti come se
esistesse un futuro anche per
quell'impresa in un mondo senza futuro
E allora guardiamo un attimo quello che
sta accadendo
questo forse era valido Come teoria
vincente fino a 30 anni fa Poi siamo
arrivati agli anni 90 quando sono nato
io e forse alcuni di voi nel 90 abbiamo
iniziato a capire che qualcosa non
funzionava e
Abbiamo indicato la luna Forse come dice
il proverbio mentre indicavamo la luna
qualcuno guardava la mano e abbiamo
iniziato ad aggiungere un altro
parametro principale quello che è
successo abbiamo iniziato a parlare in
modo sempre più importante darsi un
passo giusto di emissioni di carbonio
Quindi abbiamo iniziato a parlare di
buco dell'ozono e le missioni però in
qualche modo era un po' Come dire a
queste stesse aziende non ti preoccupare
della crisi idrica della crisi
biodiversità della Salute psicologica
dei tuoi dipendenti dire disuguaglianze
Basta che paghi una piccola Menda per
quelle che sono le tue missioni e va
tutto bene lo stesso
soltanto negli ultimi due anni siamo
arrivati ad avere una velocità di
trasformazione molto rapida per cui
ufficialmente si parla sempre di isg
questo vedete la crescita di tutti i
fondi che stanno andando in questo
settore In teoria un terzo della finanza
mondiale Oggi si sta muovendo verso il
mondo Easy gli amministratori delegati
di ogni tipo non fanno altro che
rammentare questa parola in qualunque
dichiarazione in qualunque piano voi
stessi noi stessi su Google cerchiamo
questi termini milioni milioni di volte
in più Eppure
nonostante questo percorso
l'impatto di cui tanto avevamo bisogno
l'impianto l'impatto che tanto
attendevamo non è ancora arrivato
E allora ragazzi sono qua per
raccontarvi esattamente quelli che sono
i problemi alla base di questo mondo isg
e fatemi iniziare raccontandovi il primo
il primo di questi tre problemi è il
fatto che abbiamo reso tutto questo
mondo Yahoo indice Noi guardiamo le
aziende di oggi
giudicandole con queste proxy questa
azienda è B Minus questa azienda è due
di quattro di sei queste 60 di 80 di
fatto nessuno capisce niente perché io
riesco nascondiamo dietro queste sigle i
valori veri la realtà secondo problema
questi stessi indici che adesso
criticato Di fatto sono basati su troppi
indicatori poi pensate di dover
giudicare un'azienda su 10.000 parametri
migliaia di parametri
di fatto noi stiamo creando un
arbitraggio per cui all'azienda viene
data la possibilità di raccontare una
storia in base al parametro che più
preferisce invece di concentrarsi su
quelle poche cose che contano qualcuno
in latino disse
plurime e leges correttissima Repubblica
più le leggi più corrotta e la
Repubblica
E allora ti racconto anche il terzo dei
grandi problemi che per definizione per
design tutto questo mondo jesg e oggi
basato sul rischio e non sull'impatto
per intenderci noi giudichiamo le
aziende in base a quanto hanno il
rischio di perdere di fronte alla crisi
climatica Ciò vuol dire che se noi oggi
mettiamo quel famoso euro in una start
up per un'azienda basata su valori irg
andremo a preferire Quelle aziende che
magari vi fanno ascoltare la musica o
che magari fanno giocare a un videogioco
semplicemente perché hanno poco a che
fare con tutto il rischio climatico
attorno a noi Ma di fatto quello non è
l'impatto di cui abbiamo bisogno E come
se non bastasse tutto questo oggi avere
accesso a questi dati che mi mostravo
prima avere accesso a queste
informazioni così necessarie è
costosissimo costa decine di migliaia di
euro come ancora una volta se non fosse
importante per noi tutti capire cosa c'è
dietro un prodotto o dietro un'azienda
che si interfaccia a noi
nel nostro lavoro con dei ragazzi in
gambissima abbiamo provato negli ultimi
due anni e cercare a una soluzione
Semplice efficace gratuita per dare una
trasparenza radicale a tutto questo
mondo perché Lasciatemi introdurre prima
questo concetto importante che questo
mondo di fatto oggi ha davanti due
scelte O I greenwashing il che vuol dire
che finginazione che di fatto non fai O
fai Green Ascend fai un silenzio Verdi
ti nascondi nel più totale silenzio non
comunichi quello che fai non comunichi i
tuoi dati e in ogni caso sarai molto
lontano dall'impatto di cui abbiamo
bisogno e ora ci siamo detti nel cercare
questa soluzione
c'è tanto tanto bisogno di una
trasparenza nel capire quello che c'è
dietro le nostre aziende E come starebbe
bello crei dell'incentivi positivi Dove
possiamo vedere quante donne lavorano in
quel Team Quant'è l'energia rinnovabile
che ha questa azienda nei suoi consumi
quanto sono le missioni vere che sono
dietro a quel prodotto
lui ci abbiamo creduto Perché ho
iniziato a creare tutto questo e oggi
augurarci che le nostre scelte di
acquisto le nostre scelte di Qual è il
nostro datore di lavoro le nostre scelte
di investimento possono anche basarsi su
un accesso gratuito e trasparente a
tutti questi parametri
e vedete ragazzi
pensando a tutto questo pensando alla
crisi di cui Tanto parliamo che forse la
crisi più grande di ogni generazione
vi dico che sì ci abbiamo messo tanto
ottimismo
la parola crisi in cinese
riassunta in due caratteri vuoi Jack
pericolo il pericolo di quelle terre
aride il pericolo di quelli incendi che
abbiamo visto prima ma anche
l'opportunità che è davanti a noi in un
mondo che cambia così velocemente
tocca a noi decidere se esserne guida o
essere guidati tocca a noi decidere se
possiamo dare il nostro contributo in un
mondo dove i prossimi unicorni le
prossime innovazioni saranno soluzioni
di sostenibilità scalabili e vincente
tocca a noi dire se vogliamo esserne un
alcune di queste
e io volevo dirvi che sì sono ottimista
perché da quando nel mio piccolo ho
deciso di fare Impresa qui in Italia non
faccio altro che conoscere persone come
voi persone con dei sogni incredibili
con una forza incredibile con una
concretezza incredibile e allora non
resta che augurarci che come nelle
storie nelle storie possibili
i buoni vincano sempre grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]